normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Hunter
Biden defies GOP Congressional subpoena
quote he just got into more trouble and
the GOP is vowing to initiate contempt
proceedings after Hunter Biden flouts
this subpoena to closed door testimony
uh we did talk about it a little bit
already but what do you think's going to
happen you think they're they're going
to give him the Steve Bannon treatment
he's going to go to jail because he
defied a congressional subpoena well no
because the Democrat are in charge and
they run the intelligence agencies and
the Department of Justice and their
attorney generals and of course Justice
is skewed on a political perspective but
this could also this could also be a
political pressure put on Biden saying
hey we're going to put your son in jail
unless you bow out of this election
cycle by the intellig intelligence State
we are going to go after your son yeah
but I wonder can the can the White House
pardon on contempt charges when it when
it's initiated by the Legislative Branch
because I would imagine checks and
balances are supposed to prevent this if
if Congress holds you in contempt the
the federal the federal uh the executive
branch should not be able to intervene
right I'm not an attorney I think we
need one on this one I know that's
that's interesting because Congress is
saying do this or else if the executive
branch was able to come in and say no
they don't have to that would give the
executive branch substantial power over
the legislative I'm kind of with you
Seth from what you said earlier that I I
don't I think he maybe should have a
public hearing like his testimony in
public why why not man like it's not a
that's not a partisan thing it's just
like why are they why are they trying to
get it's not family friendly they're
probably discussing a lot of things that
would be censored automatically on
YouTube that we can't even discuss here
that he particularly uh you know played
a major role in spending millions of
dollars on you know I look look like the
dude from eve6 had a great tweet and I'm
like this guy's like a lefty and so when
Hunter Biden gives the speech where he's
like talking about how he's not going to
submit to this even leftists are saying
like you've taken way too many
photographs s with crack and hookers for
anyone to defend you at this point yeah
man he's a deviant that's for sure and
that's the that's that's that's the
least that's the least B bad thing he
did I would like to ask him all right
how he that's admirable for for a lot of
other people I think like $800,000 on on
H $688,000 reportedly on they're called
L we know there was more it's said
various women over what period of Time
how many women how many times a day like
I want to know some numbers
apparently he wants you to know the
numbers too he's proud maybe he's proud
of it he's like yo I'm going down I want
everyone to know what I in my life yeah
like just kind of curious at this point
how long over how many years did he
spend that 688,000 four maybe or
something but but hold on hold on let's
be let's be real $688,000 on various
women could also mean he bought them
dinners you know he flew them on private
jets staying in hotel on islands and
things I'm not I'm not sure the
reporting was that he literally gave
that much to women for their company if
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah again
this is something we should get to in
the inquiry I'd like to imagine I mean I
mean let's just think about this life I
mean the dude is basically living in a a
just a a swamp of debauchery and I feel
bad for him it's like a cursed existance
where he's just covered in slime yeah
literally 700 Grand on hookers dude yeah
these women have some slime diseas
that's that's on the
record that's not cash imagine what the
cash purchases here okay that that's
yeah cuz there's a lot of withdrawals
like I'm I'm C like from the videos the
things I've seen out of Hunter Biden
these were not really high-end women so
I feel like this is a lot of different
women like it's not like he's getting
the you know right cuz they're talking
30 40 bucks
pop he's got he's got to go a long way
to get up to 7K that's what I'm saying
like another 40 oh man under a bridge I
mean dude the videos aren't there like
videos where he's got like three women
yeah but they everything I've seen they
look rough these women could not be
charging a lot that's what I'm I agree
so we're talking like he's finding like
three or four women and giving them each
like 100 bucks to get to 700k is a lot
maybe he just gives a ton H by so that
one special girl he gave like 300
EXA right it's like one woman Maui
100 treated her right for six months
yeah drove her around and and was there
a movie about this what was that famous
movie ber no no no Pretty Woman yes yeah
yeah yeah apparently it was a very dark
movie in the beginning and that changed
Julia Roberts was saying I didn't know
oh it was supposed to be like really
nasty yeah apparently I mean the movie
is fairly bad yeah I don't know how
women treat like oh such a love tail
like it's kind of she's a
hooker I know like she was literally a
street corner hooker and everybody such
a sweet tale it's funny how this story
with Hunter has these dichotomies like
he's like my father my parents took such
good like I feel sad for a human going
through this crappy life with a super
famous dad that didn't give him enough
attention and just bought him out of
trouble but at the same time like bro if
you used your dad's money and he was had
like cycling political influence that's
like fullon political we cannot tolerate
that in our government anymore we've got
to we're at the age of we're coming to
the age of Aquarius but the age of
openness like the the apocalypse is upon
us you you can't and Well that took a
dark turn yeah apocalypse meaning the
Great Awakening the great um revealment
like we're in this age of revealment
we're like I I just I don't I don't hate
this guy it's just like what can we let
it stand can we pardon him and just be
like yo what you did can never happen
again but we're not going to destroy
ourselves and you okay hold on there a
minute the the drugs and the hookers is
a hunter you need some help I'm I'm
hearing that you're getting clean
correct this is good for you now let's
move on to the bribery the influence
pedaling the funneling money to your dad
yeah cuz he and Joe they could have too
the the checks for the big guy the money
the shared bank accounts yeah yeah the
the Ukrainian oligarchs and business
deals that they had with with what was
the oil company again barisma barisma
for freak's sakes when you look at
what's happening in Ukraine holy cow
there are so many corrupted politicians
there and that whole case should have
been properly investigated Trump even
just trying to investigate it was
impeached for just trying to do that
which was absolutely crazy and now we're
going to finally investigate it what's
up what's going on here since of course
he was protected before now he's not I
think something's up what if uh what if
Hunter flips
oh wow like imagine imagine the GOP and
Trump they go to him and they say not
only are you going to be pardoned you're
going to be a hero just tell everybody
what happened with barisma and then what
if he comes out and says we called my
dad and asked him to intervene on our
behalf and then Joe is just like oh crap
because think about it this gets Joe
out it gives Democrats an opportunity to
bring in
Nome yeah and I would I think a lot more
people be willing to par pardon Hunter
if he comes out clean say so Joe might
say throw them into the bus this is what
we want then the Democrats bring in Nome
you'll get pardoned people will cheer
for you for calling us out for calling
out the corruption or whatever you're
not going to be you're not going to be
perfect in the eyes but you you'll have
some Redemption Arc and then they can
bring in Nome and someone super chated
saying it's going to be Whitmer Nome
Whitmer yep I I saw that too and then uh
Biden will will pass on and then Hunter
Biden will become the next uh politician
that will probably become the next
president of the I don't think that'll
happen but you got to it's like man with
uh uh Joe Biden is is is clearly on the
way out not all there right now the play
for a father to save his son is to say
to his son I mean do you think Joe Biden
has that much dignity and self resect to
throw himself off for his son I think I
think the root of corruption typically
is familial and friend friendly bonds
the reason why they engage in this level
of corruption is to is to enrich
themselves I I do believe Joe Biden
cares about his kids and I do believe he
probably abused his kids you know to a
great degree so maybe car isn't the
right word but my point is the Democrats
want Nome man they got to get Joe Biden
out how do you do it the inquiry is slow
moving and right now a bunch of people
like wait a minute wait a minute we
don't want Joe Biden impeached and
convicted because we want him to run
against Trump Democrats need to get
somebody in what Democrats just make Joe
Biden like climb a bunch of really tall
stairs a lot between now and the
election I think odds would be in their
favor he won't make it no because
there's something that happens to people
at his age where with with cellular
regeneration operating at such a low
percentage stressing the body actually
does not improve him it degrades him
faster no I'm saying he's going to fall
and oh right I thought you saying the
work no no work out we're P you're right
we're past workout yeah that's no no
that's darker thought there the the the
I'm I'm just saying maybe it won't be
Hunter Biden coming out and being like I
must tell the truth it might be
something like you know look yeah we
called my dad he did it and then
everyone goes we got him we got Joe
Biden the conservatives get to scream
and rub in the Democrats faces but then
they bring in Gavin Nome I think they're
too arrogant I don't think it'll happen
they these people never think they're
really going to ever get caught because
they control everything they are the
Deep State they live in such a world of
I don't know where the word is but
they're they control it all when it
comes to the Deep State they have no
fear of themselves being grown in jail
for protesting or anything else like
that so I don't think so I think I mean
I I get what you're saying but what
you're saying is almost a rational
approach I don't know that they're going
to take a rational approach I I I I
think you may be right but but consider
this a basic chess move no smart move I
think I don't know that they're going to
make that smart move though also I don't
think Hunter would do it because his
life would be forfeit if he he spoke
opposite no this was Dave Hunter if
Hunter exposed the Deep States plots in
Ukraine Hunter no no no no no no you
misunderstand the Deep State wants
Hunter to do it they need Joe Biden out
Joe Biden can't beat Trump how do you
get Nome in it's a it's a great play I
don't know if it's a perfect play but on
the surface you get Hunter Biden Joe
Biden son is saved Hey Joe we want you
out no I don't want to leave okay well
we're going to we're going to save your
son by having him come out and and and
provide evidence that removes you from
Office your son will be saved you will
be out Nome comes in Nome gives us the
war we want I guess if Hunter could
expose some of the dealings without
letting the American people know that
they kind of got us into the war and you
like their corruption with barisma like
accelerated this he will only reveal
what the Deep State wants him to in
order to remove Joe Biden and get Nome
Whitmer in I'm not saying it's not the
worst thing in the world this guy's got
a long life to live I don't think he
wants to die or like go to jail or any
of that I also think Joel if if you
think Joe doesn't have the Integrity to
save his to sacrifice himself for his
son okay then consider he doesn't have
the pers City or the cognitive faculties
to understand what's happening at all
that's Clos to realityy Hun's going to
be like my dad did it that's and uh he's
he's crooked what can I say I'm sorry
American
people Joe's response
is and that's it yeah Hunter has to go
to the CIA and say hey I I'll do
whatever you guys want me to do we'll
take out my dad I'm really pissed at my
dad as of course A lot of people are
also kind of theorizing that a lot of
what came out through the laptop was
kind of a deliberate release since there
are many serious accusations against uh
Joe Biden hurting his children
especially with the hunter uh especially
with the the Biden diary that the FBI
was after specifically even raiding the
home of James O'Keefe after that uh they
kind of verified the findings in which
essentially detailed some very
disturbing events that unfolded between
uh Joe Biden and his uh younger daughter
so a lot of people are saying maybe
Hunter Biden released all the details of
his laptop maybe he deliberately tried
to get it publicized in order to bring
down his father as a part of a
retribution uh plan to finally get some
justice against him for possibly hurting
and abusing him at the very least like
subconsciously I can see that happening
cuz like I've I've been really high in
my life and like had such self-hatred
that I would allow that stuff came out
that was like true that I wouldn't
normally say if I was sober but but
listen Bill Clinton said House of Cards
is 99% accurate for a reason and when
you watch that TV series uh you see a
lot of backstabbing you see people just
you know take each other out politically
in so many uh dastardly uh ways and you
see a lot of really Sinister activities
of people just screwing each other over
all the time that's Washington DC so I
think everything is at play here because
the establishment is going to lose they
are going to lose their main puppet
their main frontman their main skin suit
that allows them to implement whatever
policies they want on the American
people no matter how unpopular they're
able to do it through Joe Biden why
would they give it up if they're going
to lose this upcoming election no matter
what they need something else that is
going to be happening behind the scenes
that we might not even know of that's
happening right now we have to just make
sure that we don't trash ourselves the
Americans the in the meantime while this
is happening so that the global banking
takes this country over that would be
the worst possible outcome like the
Trump Biden all this Republican Democrat
crap has to be put aside for American
Unity com coming in 2020 it's so
important thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net